get ready for the most infamous love
story in cinema history our vampire
journey begins in forks a town that
seems to be perpetually damn we meet
bella a girl so awkward and
uncoordinated even her friends aren't
safe
even though bella seems to be extremely
boring everyone wants to talk to and be
around her not this guy edward though he
would rather just stare at her and bella
would rather just breathe awkwardly back
at him
and so begins their unique relationship
after edward saves her life he reveals
himself to be a sparkly vampire letting
the secret out on the vampire world
vampire they are immortal creatures who
have super strength super speed and
super good looks we meet the cullens who
luckily for bella don't consume human
blood they'd rather play baseball these
vampires also love a good game of
baseball except they want to kill bella
which kind of puts a damper on the game
you brought a snack bad guy james
tortures bella films the ordeal then
bites her on the wrist luckily edward
arrives to weirdly suck the venom out
and save her life all that's left to do
now is go to prom and have one last
awkward moment with bella's dad i put a
new can of pepper spray in your bag